yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
Julie from the US I'm careful and now I
learned that there are some flags that
from from while a distance looks like
the US but it isn't ok so in English
defends the e6b 6 opening and key plate
with a 3 or she played you never know um
ok yeah I think getting the 922 e-form
is a a good way to to play I think this
is some how I how I studied it while ago
when I thought about playing the Sun in
regular tournament games I played it a
couple of times this ecigs b6 setups it
has one yoochun yeah one huge advantage
in practical play white usually am
doesn't know the ins and outs so well so
that's some very often that you don't
get the best possible lines played
against you ok so one idea is to quickly
get to e4 and especially after Knight f3
94 is very natural white cannot even
take after F takes Eve and then eat XD 5
i'm going to win the d5 pawn so he
probably needs to play something like
Bishop d2
or Quincy to you don't want to get your
pawn structure damaged here so probably
some move to allow a recapture on c3
with the piece should be to queen yeah
Quincy to this desire to move I don't
really think he can play or she can play
on something else the name in that well
very long text I won't manage to read
that now and then there's no move coming
I hope it's not a disconnect or
something no yeah that's really weird I
mean I tend to spend lots of time but
this is taking it to two extremes and
okay so white allowed to get the pawn
structure damaged young where to put
this this Bishop yeah quite often this
is a good square it simply blocks the
blocks d5 d6 which often can be a
tactical a tactical issue here white
could play Knight b5 and and take it oh
this was stupid I didn't really think
about that hmm on Bishop g2 there's
night f5 and this is really ugly
I what a blunder yeah I just relax too
much after wide spent so much time and
now I've basically busted I didn't see
anything else that in all castles yeah
this is a simple solution just take on
f5 and now take on disease very ugly
position okay the endgame is this is
very bad but maybe there are still
better chances to fight then in the
middle game where my king also would be
week after if you imagine this with the
Queen's on like Queen a 4 and so on how
do i have ever defend my king so the
same this is maybe maybe the better
tribe okay want to get counterplay may
be getting the c-4 porn I'm I'm one porn
down and of course the deep one is very
very weak but at least them White has
got to this double porn and now if white
takes on d6 I take on c4 this is not
compensation but something to to fight
yeah the bishop will find a an excellent
home on onda form
okay yeah how to how to play that his
bishop is very strong him
hmm yeah I need to improve why my night
but the towel how to do that and which
square 95 okay 95 detects III jack III
sm rather passive linking
I want to be able to play be five on a
five so it's still a pin here so
I don't let it be checked King c6 devil
my
yeah it's just it's just a very crappy
position
yeah it's not just the pawn it's this
this is Bishop here the porn would be
bad enough probably but the bishop
really is is terrible to play against
yaanai d6 especially five check job I
didn't I didn't really see that but what
position is this terrible yeah I just
had this um check this lapse of
concentration where I we're allowed the
channeler this capture only six before
that white was really in bad shape check
check maybe I get some counter play
check
and absolutely everyone would take care
why doesn't it take completely time
triangles check check check check check
check check check check oh it's a draw
check check game drawn yeah it's a draw
yeah I simply forgot that the SD takes
you six I mean here unless there's
something yep maybe we should be sixes
bed went along the structure is a
terrible decision form for white like
it's already a very very comfortable
maybe 94 is the move I don't know what's
clear is what I play it let's put this
quickly yeah that here I mean maybe
castles or something but this is
especially bad because i am not even
able to take here because of this move
and this is very embarrassing yeah just
just a blunder Queenie 7s terrible I
just thought Queenie 7 and whatever I
didn't I didn't think about the capture
at all I can maybe castle after that
this kind of position Oh mrs. playable
it's strange though can can take this is
much better in comparison to the game
but still I probably should be six is
already a bit of it I mean maybe there's
room for improvement let's put it that
way I could consider c5 now I can't be
sure their forms from not so great yeah
I don't know but what I played is
definitely very bad okay thanks for
watching